hello everyone as you all know the Lord
has blessed us and helped us hear a
clash of Mines to continue to produce
WhatsApp Prof episodes every week for
the past three and a half years and 171
episodes
we have consistently stated that we will
continue to produce WhatsApp Prof
episodes and this is still our aim we
intend to push forward with WhatsApp
Prof by his grace and until it is
impossible to do so
in the spirit of Prophecy it is stated
that if we are found busy with spreading
the Three Angels messages and
establishing Bible schools that teach
the Three Angels messages and combine
this with the right arm of the Gospel
namely the health message
in health centers then we will hear the
words well done good and faithful
servant enter thou into the joy of the
Lord when Jesus comes to fetch us
for this reason we earnestly prayed and
asked the Lord to show us how he would
have us go about doing what he asked he
has opened the doors and closed some
which gave us the opportunity to
establish a health center that will run
during the year but two or three times a
year for a short intake period the
center will serve as a bible school to
teach and equip students with short but
comprehensive courses on the Three
Angels messages and how to spread them
more information on these projects will
follow soon
with all these projects requiring
full-time dedication and energy it has
become necessary to rejuvenate our
energies in order to carry forward this
most important work therefore I'm
announcing that WhatsApp Prof will be
taking a break but we will be back as
soon as possible
there are other wonderful presentations
that will continue to be uploaded to our
Clash of mine channels on the various
platforms and on our download server all
the links to these channels on the
various platforms can be found in the
description of the Clash of Mines
YouTube videos and also on our website
at clashofminds.com
we encourage you to watch and share
these videos and also to revisit some of
the earlier episodes of WhatsApp Prof
because our message since episode 1 has
never changed
we at Clash of Mines want to sincerely
thank all of you for your prayers and
wonderful support please continue to
pray for us because the devil is walking
around like a roaring lion seeking whom
he may devour see you all again soon may
God bless you
[Music]
foreign